لم يفوت عاملان نظافه توني دومال
اي مظاهره مناهضه لقانون التقاعد الجديد
ويثير حنقهما اليوم اصرار الحكومه على
فرضه رغم ما يعتبرانه اجماعا شعبيا على
رفضه
انظروا حولكم هل يمحي لكم هذا الانطباع
بان الامور حسمت بالعكس انظروا هذا الحشد
لا شيء حسم انا عامل نظافه ولا استطيع
الاستمرار الى سن الرابعه وستين معلقا
بمؤخره شاحنه اجمع اكياس القمامه هناك
العديد من زملائي ماتوا قبل بلوغ هذه السن
لا شيء على ما يرام في البلد وهو يحاول
فرض شروطه ويصم اذانه كي لا يسمع صوت
الشعب استمع لهم انهم غاضبون وان كان
ماكرون لا يريد التنازل فنحن بالمثل لن
نتنازل
الشعارات التي رفعت في المظاهره ترفض
المساس بالمكاسب الاجتماعيه للفرنسيين
وتندد
ايسي ماكرون ايذاء مطالب شعبه متهمه اياه
بالانحياز الى مصالح الاثرياء على حساب
الفقراء تقول لي مقروء عليه ان يستمع
للشعب نحن لسنا هنا لاضاعه الوقت نقوم
بتضحيات وعليه ان يستمع لشعبه لقد حان
الوقت لذلك
حاله الاحتقان في صفوف المتظاهرين تسببت
بتصاعد التوتر في بعض شوارع العاصمه
الفرنسيه حيث عمد بعضهم الى حرق حاويات
النفايات وتكسير بعض الواجهات الزجاجيه
فردت الشرطه بالغاز الموسيلي للدموع وشن
عدد من الاعتقالات
[موسيقى]
يؤكد لم تحسم بعد وان شارع الفرنسيه لم
يقطع الامل لحمل الحكومه عبر التظاهر
والاضراب على سحب قانونها لطف المسعودي
الجزيره باريس